hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Fran bow and
hopefully this is gonna be the final
episode of Fran bow I'm very sorry for
the long delay on getting to this game
winter vacation got in the way but
that's no excuse you guys deserve the
entertainment of rainbows interesting
life and hopefully get to finally get to
the bottom of why Fran bow is having all
these hallucinations so we just became a
human which is good and all and I
suppose and now that I am a human things
are probably not gonna go so good for me
and they're probably not gonna go so
good for me when I get back to the place
where everyone else is just trying to be
on the lookout for anything suspicious
around here because as an impressionable
young girl I wouldn't want to see
anything too freaky hopefully actually
start to understand why Fran bow is Oh
everything's fine you know I have a lot
of questions about that number one the
seat full of hands that's a little weird
to me
the doll cat does that anything to do
with the robocat I saw in the beginning
of the game and also why are you crying
bud and the skulls and the dress weird
it feels like heaven what are you leave
mr. midnight alone he's your head
playing with you again can't you see
yourself in the mirror I'm not you I'm
not let mr. midnight go meow wait kill
the traitors because that's what he is
Fran don't you see my kitty is not a
traitor
he promised me to be by my side don't
mind my voice cracking Hubert he's
coming along has your mommy and daddy
did who promised to take good care of
you wake up friend you are surrounded by
traitors me alone what do you say let's
be happy oh yeah you look so happy on
your throne of hands with the weird
eyeballs they're looking all around is
that from made from the stolen souls of
your victims me let's be so very oh oh
jeez go away go hey it wasn't me Oh God
okay Oh
oh it's you I don't remember your voice
either I'm crazy sir I'm totally bonkers
you whoo-whoo-whoo the doctors were
right flippity baby ba but you're not
crazy I'm very sorry you feel that way
oh that's right i mispronounced eiated
thing you should be happy now
you found the stone eggs and you become
a human again that is very great indeed
my dear let me wipe those tears I don't
want to hurt you my dear oh wait oh and
I feel like I'm about to do it at any
moment
you won't I know that because you love
me
yes kitty I do love you very much except
for the fact that I'm totally crazy and
just saw myself murdering you but I'm
not gonna tell you that pretty kitty
not to your face Fran remember what I
told you if you love you are a love a
and that is the only thing that matters
you will always find the poor to fight
those monsters in you now let's go and
open the got a so you can go home a yes
yes let's do this even though it's
probably gonna flood this world with
monstrosity the likes of which you
lovely tree folk have never seen all
right kitty let's go on a wonderful
adventure of death and destruction
I mean happiness and other stuff where
was this game am I supposed to follow
him la dee da dee da flippidy baby Dee
here we are I guess just walk off that
land
she'll be fine yes but where is the door
all right
don't walk off the let's let me close
your eyes let me wave my magic wand and
then you lock off the ledge are you sure
you want to go back I'm sure sir all
right here we go whatever doesn't matter
to me the human must leave open the
secret door into her reality or whatever
human return home I cry to the heavens
and no one in particular
oh wow we are going home kitty maybe
oh hi how's it going wizard good a deal
i brought the stones so this lovely
creature can go home it's amazing how we
have the same voice isn't it
totally a coincidence nobody questioned
anything here thank you sir
I'm very nervous it will be strange to
be far away from you all although is
stranger the entire time that I was here
I didn't know this place existed and
frankly I'd like to forget my entire
experience here you can make a place to
stay a very magical place wizard she has
to leave I received a message from one
of the villages blackest led glowy
thingies and she is not ready oh I see
what are you talking about ready for
what I'm ready for anything
I probably murdered my parents in my
murder my cat come on wizard Laser
sounds we have no time to lose but ready
for what why won't anyone tell me
anything I'm just a nine year old girl
twelve I don't know you know what you
know what the black is told you about
facing your truth yes I think I remember
not really though it was a long time ago
well should i yes go ahead wizard sir
magic stones Cree the lock the human can
break something
again I'm shouting the Noli particular
through my jellybeans at the wall and
hopefully that did something well now
time for friend to be the key I guess
you're a tree before or not be a key you
are the only one who could open this now
oh okay I believe you I guess let me
just use my 10 year old intellect hoping
to be able to birth
hmm I'll just eat these jelly beans and
hopefully something will happen
oh look guys we're all out of magic
stones oh I see it's a puzzle it's one
of them puzzle things okay I got it oh
hey last piece whoa I made a storm I
remember doing that in second grade boy
it's good star making also opening
portals to other worlds you did your
friend you can go home now I'm so
excited I think oh I wish I could leave
you something so you can remember me
surely you wouldn't remember the only
human walking through this world ever we
won't forget you you're a very special
cranberry
oh forgot Poloncarz gave me this for you
oh I don't know what the hell it is but
you can have it oh thank you for
whatever the hell this is
tell pelant restate I wish I could help
him with his wounds I gave my aid
patches to a girl in the hospital don't
worry
Alondra sees better now but maybe oh oh
oh before you go you must know before
you returning your reality you will go
through this woods
passage between our realities Oh things
a little girl wouldn't understand
counter terrible creatures that want to
eat you I've never been there personally
I only hear stories about things that go
into there never return unless like a
half-eaten torso gets tossed back
through that portal to Hell thing you're
looking at whatever small details down
yeah router router on just run run
really fast as fast as you can they're
probably slow and you're telling me this
now huh that sounds very scary good
appropriate reaction there little girl
don't worry you'll do cranberry he I
hope so
well mr. midnight say goodbye let's go
now goodbye gentlemen I had a great time
meow-meow I I like you very much goodbye
we into the portals of nightmares going
into the woods to be eaten alive ok
goodbye this reality what the hell
happened to pelant hrus oh oh oh hi oh
oh I was I didn't know who was playing a
game I forgot
turned into Mario oh ho I'm all hopped
up on cranberries you'll never get me
even though you're some weird bizarre
giant moss-like thing with an obvious
penis dangling between your legs
I know something tells me that's not
appropriate well I fell and died to my
death oh god I'll be right back
where where where where where where
where well I'm gonna make it I'm gonna
wreck it oh don't mind that the hills
are all staring at me is this an analogy
for The Hills Have Eyes is this the
Hills Have Eyes three return of the
return of the eyepatch I don't know nor
I said that joke okay alright we made it
to the tree door chapter 4 part 1 my
imaginary friend blood
who's my imaginary friend
oh that's normal oh yeah okay so is my
assumption correct and believing that
this is actually just the imaginations
of a little girl and actually has
nothing to do with anything my goodness
the door opened Wow interesting
other explains Tori Marx come on mr.
midnight let's find out where we are
this mister there's mr. midnight okay
that's not good
Oh Fran I hope we can find home soon I'm
starving
we were only in there for 14,000 years
mr. midnight look I think we're on the
other side of the bridge
maybe boy that was a long detour down
into the pits of nothingness do you
remember the one we tried to cross
before we fell in their thirst oh I
don't know it was 14,000 I mean I
remember okay great let's keep going
kitty we have to be careful now I'm so
scared I'm stuttering are these my pills
Wow well where are they going boy I can
understand the whole reality of
realities but I can't seem to understand
anything else it's very odd when we fell
into a thirst day there was no water
ah I wonder if we really fell maybe we
fell upside-down yeah that's the
appropriate logic for a young girl like
me
okay all right so someone's luring me
with my pills which I'm home oh wait a
minute hang on here
I might be a little girl but something
tells me something made perfectly right
here pills don't move Oh God pills oh
come on
no I just want to go home oh oh you
better not move on me again
berries oh can you want some berries oh
you pop Oh God Oh curse your sudden but
inevitable just betrayal I shouldn't
have touched the pills bad Fran bad bad
oh no what should it be to now we're
trapped forever and ever I'll look at
this box great
it's got symbols I can't read wonder
wonder okay how about the knife what a
long fall I would have laughed at best
sent us Oh
oh hi hey friend Fran oh hey I give this
guy good boys Fran you're already here
no that's gonna tear up my voice let me
try another one
friend don't hold ready here I was
neglecting you two interesting let me
introduce myself I am is Ward a friend
before oh it's what I don't remember you
from somewhere you seem familiar
mister huh I think I managed quite well
to find my own kitty on my own hey
aren't you the one that made this
sisters mad no it wasn't me making the
system mad they believed it with me I
also was in the window when a closed
door there you see but that's because
they never looked into themselves good
places my headphones won't stay what if
what did you say about headphones make
nor me what do you mean by they never
looked into themselves they could do
nothing but do that they were together
forever they blamed me facing the facts
oh that's a bit extreme man the long man
with the long hat of booties a top hat
bio is king baggage and produce stories
when he was just a little Bailey you
know back before you could form memories
I cling to you after you imagined me
Mikey falling off unimportant the
reality did I imagine you wow what an
active imagination I have I can't deny
that
whoopty woo do I believe me booboo I'll
just be focused the truth is that you
are able because I don't look into that
too much it makes less sense the more
you think about it take me home I can't
let you do that I don't know you my
teeth alright you seem nice I'll go with
you but I won't trust you yet excuse the
long legs very gangly excuse my creepy
gait very suspicious I know mrs. top hat
there's nothing under it all the weird
death machine behind me oh I mean the is
word flying machine wear red red Lee
let's see can it fly
it's alright but can it really fly
gorgeous piece of death I'll take you to
death home the detail good night
it's God who's any higher yet that
sounds great but what about 35 zero
understand a chance to look close a
reality once again don't think about it
too much it's really deadly in the
ultra-reality
this idea for reality we've traveled
abroad Rio right now we're standing on
the edge here you understand I bet you
don't
yes I do Wow it sounds insane but I
understand it one plus one equals I'm
insane should I just wait until you're
done thank you visible to my eyes okay
all right okay I was trying to catch the
pills earlier but the trap caught me
first okay it's okay sir I defeated the
trap like into one second or she's going
full teenager on him anyway I'll go get
the you asked me for great probably
preparing the death machine okay thank
you
well what does this pill say about you
if that's an analogy for me to not trust
this guy because that's kind of like an
idea ill I look completely deformed am i
nutritious I bet I am
tasty fresh flesh oh boy
they're the kalamos what about the fire
berries
what is that Wow so much hair it's so
shiny magical world okay so those
probably aren't the fire berries I oh hi
hi how's it going there friend get out
get out you're trespassing on my Dara
Tory no manners at all
I'm very sorry uh remaining skeleton and
little bits of flesh seem to be all run
and bloody ramen bloody I think you're
misunderstanding the situation why do
you say that mr. moose mr. moose I'm not
a moose I'm a deadly worm a deadly no no
not a deadly war my deadly worm I don't
go grunt killing creatures I just get
back to the soul with the creatures took
in from in don't need any more but I
only see a talking moose where are you
oh hi ah ah you're cute
ah you're dynein kidding terrifying and
horrible oh why didn't you touch the
moose I don't know
okay of course not I'm trying to see if
I can climb on it to reach them for
that's not what I was thinking of when I
first clicked on that inhale is that way
I think it's possible the Moose is still
very sturdy and solid okay but the fire
berries are on fire fire fire
you can hear yourself yes I see the fire
but I have to take them somehow good
luck with that
climb on now I'll keep working thank you
sir
I guess those lovely help oh no I didn't
mean to go up there oh can I crayon that
I can't take the fire berries they're on
fire hey what are you doing back there
yeah you just said so the sign to hell
is pointed oh hi it's you again hello
are you those shiny insects that gets
stuck on the trees because of curiosity
usually yeah how do you know this you're
not one of us I met one of you a long
time in my weirdo travels in the forest
yes I think curiosity is a good thing
especially when you're in a hellscape of
blood and death oh yeah we're not stuck
we're just trying to make our hair long
as you're ever yeah that's amazing okay
good luck with that I guess so what's
down there it's blood alrighty so I need
some water so I guess I might be able to
use some hair use on that guy if you lie
me to tie this bucket to your beautiful
hair that's argent I need water from the
cliff blah blah blah I need to use your
long beautiful hair as a rope alright
blabbity blah fill the hole bug it up
I was rather Badou she going Thank You
buckets now full of water take my word
for it and it's not blood
definitely not blood sure yeah but this
home belongs somewhere I don't
understand the question
I'm nine I don't understand these deep
philosophical rhetorical questions you
just wanted to say that you are your own
home
welcome yourself inside you will find
many doors to open I don't like that
rhetorical question
that's a weird rhetorical question it
sounds mysterious and beautiful and
creepy a little bit I'll try to do that
some other time though goodbye
alright bucket full of water doesn't
weigh anything almost as if it's in my
hey shut up it's me it's me sir can I
climb please please I need the fire
berries they're on yeah okay here we go
ah I got it I can't just pull them off
with my hand they're firmly attached to
you for a little girl gasp or maiming
okay totally fine Oh what was I worried
about okay fine I'm getting a little
loopy that's what happens when you play
this game for too long you start to see
lots of horrible things like that oh
well done dude Meister man let you find
the fire batteries walk
already we need them for the journey
back home I got I got something yeah
negative Hey ha ha sir I brought the
fire berries but they're not on fire
anymore thank you very much my darling
okay how about this bucket of water Sir
Edward here's the bucket full of water
also I remember the name it word being
put on a guy in a basement who is like
dead stuff not good Wow
burn me well I haven't been into the
fifth reality and I hope I don't go
there just machine for killing just very
gently cannot overstate the Decimus
so then there I am oh it's a spaceship
it's 236 we have a great possibility
everything a target in good condition
well soon be on our way to Hood reality
are you excited maybe I would be excited
if I could understand more about the
realities just spend all time flipping
through a book goes as it has to in
order to be alive I speak in cryptic
messages and now I'm very final if it
all happened now you'd probably lose for
some reason are you telling me that the
answers I'm looking for will come to me
when they want very few before a little
girl I'd rather say through time you
have to explore and experience to
understand do you understand yes it will
come when you find them not when others
tell you where to find them oh I see
well I'm excited now you woke up my
curiousness mistis okay bad news guys
doing the shakes give me a shake I know
some of you are so eager for that voice
to keep going on but uh kind of stirring
up the old brain noggin a little bit
mixing up my words not doing good for me
a screw it I'll keep going the best
thing you can hope for is realm we're
curious and you're always amazed
talking won't ride you home
what things sir I'm going to talk a lot
more the breed is maintenance blah blah
blah you a lot of just oh I never done
this before
are you gonna talk more driving oh god
my head alright I'll go now thank you oh
my head oh man my brain is not okay what
do we have here ah
Oh Oh why'd he cut off a foot oh oh wow
you know how I picked a voice that
wouldn't damage my my voice okay so
let's move on now to another room very
quietly oh hello I remember you okay
goodbye
so for now we're gonna go back to a calm
quiet let's play one that'll be a bit
easier on my voice so we have a
chemistry station and some tubing that
we need pinkos to connect blue lows to
connect and one unchecked
so we need some AFM if I'm not mistaken
oh I probably should not be mixing these
like this probably very bad okay let's
get out of here
so what we need now is an idea oh I see
so we need this is going to be very
difficult in 16 and 166 to our 15 to pf2
8/18
AFM mixing all together to make what
that I do not know oh there's a lot of
doodads in here maybe perhaps the fire
berries nope nevermind then I'll just go
into a different room why don't I the
dog and through hello again I still
can't talk to you you would think that
my cat would want to speak with you
about something or other
okay there's got to be some sort of idea
what I'm supposed to be doing in the
other room also this person has oh look
it's a picture of the king very
interesting and it seems that it works
has many other cat friends like me wait
a minute that's not right so through
here the doors closed maybe Edward can
open it later okay oh wait ladder there
we go that leads to a door but it's oh
well that's not comforting
so there's gotta be a way to open the
door up there so I need to find another
way around
Louella phoneme monstrum de-spawn
they're colorful do it in belief care
support Amos mom alley is K ha knob
Jamal are got a good crowd okay
Joey's Caleb ignore everything about it
oh okay so water goes in there ah that's
a water pump here I was thinking it was
a fire very bub
okay this makes no sense Oh No
good thing I have some of this alright
close that up turn that there we go
okay I got it I got it
okay like the fire it was sideways I'd
like to look at the diagram to get that
particularly right so now that that's on
that should be able to heat some water
which is good watch why do I need that
why in particular do I need
oh hello oh okay
feels like something is missing yeah key
from the keyhole well damn it now I got
a knife
how about that won't work huh well
that's stupid and you're stupid for
being stupid it's our way to do this
maybe there's a secret code or something
I don't know
so there's that let's oh is that any of
em ah but there's a bottle up there I
want me some AFM oh oh okay ah okay so
we put the fire berries inside of that
with the fire and then we should be able
okay so AFM was the fire berries oh that
makes more sense okay so now I can
follow the instructions of the wall
supposedly even though this doesn't seem
to be perfectly working correctly
10:16 FMA 18 to PF are 15 and 166 that's
what I thought I put in there oh okay I
got more tubing hello who are you
seconds and minutes and hours and days
okay that's not very descriptive what do
I need all right some hose with a sort
of connector I know what that goes to
also there's eyeballs
what's with the eyeballs do you not have
eyeballs and I have many apples cuz you
got eyeballs draped all over the place I
want to stop saying the word eyeballs
now what about Oh oh hey word how are
you doing now your bouncy weird voice
makes a lot more sense
okay cool so what reality is am I
looking at you oh ah little ki are you
are you here to kill it word hello
why won't you talk to me I'm very sorry
for what I did I everything forgive me
or whatever okay so that was fun I got a
key out of it I got some hoses now I
should be able to do what I need to do
in a world made of darkness and light do
Little Sisters tried to steal each
other's time but none of the thighs
could decide if what they were was just
too right Neos angry and clawed I was
sad and this was because they were both
were mad who insane little girls inside
of their mind
it was the creature of the night he came
always around in dreams or reality
teaching the girls the splendor of
duality but they couldn't understand
they couldn't comprehend it word was a
friend a friend Julian it word was a
link between darkness and lights he was
grey
he was ghoulish he was oh such a fright
but Clara and Mia one day decided to get
her heed of it word once and for all
creature of the night said are they
killed each other instead
dead and gone des fled and flan the
sisters kept complaining about each
other to their own mother it's all your
fault Clara it's all your fault mara
then it word came to visit for the last
time and he said everything is arrived
you are both trapped in the world of
discretions what I'll give you a chance
the world has been mean to you they
sewed your bodies together to prove that
they couldn't they gave you a mirror to
compare yourselves I'll give you nothing
but what you already have and just one
tiny little chance to understand the
purpose of life but the clock is ticking
and my nose is picking you have until
the day of Black Cat goes missing and
the well loves magic door is unlocked
the end well I don't feel like I learned
a lot of life lessons from that I feel
like I'm more haunted than I was when I
went into that exercise in fact I feel
like a very dizzy and not feeling good
at all anyway let's finish this thing
now that we actually have all the pieces
now so this to Daddy goes da and the dis
dude it goes
we are nope wait let me look at the
picture I took all my phone maybe the
Baba to be able to Bobby to be able to
Baba - where is oh it's at the bottom
okay baby - Bobby to be able to Baba -
Oh boom boom baby - Bobby to be able to
Bobby boom boom boom maybe the Bobby to
be able to Bobby is it working now
sploosh oh oh that would make so much
sense I can click and hold them that's
so much easier I have no idea I honestly
have no idea okay so that did that oh
yeah that's right I need super chemistry
master Fran bow for some reason oh boy
okay so that's that then right wow that
took a long-ass time I'm hardly matters
a fixie automatic driver help I think I
managed myself quite well I cooked
ninety-eight percent purity crystal meth
you talk to any little girl I can do
that
I leave my own yes everything looks
absolutely great what should we do now
sir I wanted to ask you if you are
afraid of wabbits rooms and I'm depends
on a rabbit sir with all things I've
seen I can't just imagine one kind of
rabbit it is a chocolate rabbit a one
with horns and killer eyes you know
potato potato
murder and not murder you want to see
for yourself
it has a pink nose and blue
like it does sound very scary sir but
show to me otherwise I'll never know I'm
just a little girl seeing is believing
for me for some reason brain yeah poor
little me now Klunk Klunk my bony bones
with shoes with human feet on them where
we're going now
bing-bong open the door thank you
alright let's find this rabbit whatever
maybe the rabbit is scared and that's
why I won't move would you please try to
make contact with it okay you big whiny
skeleton baby with sharp teeth and clown
alternate-reality face okay this is
exactly our Monty Python wind oh you're
right Fred Oh No
Oh betrayal oh boy betrayal
okay see I knew something wasn't right
here oh I got a carrot what happens if I
give the carrot to mr. wabbit II think
stop working makes me agree all right I
got a wrench got some lightbulbs paper
thingy covering up a doodad air1 inna
little bit okay
aha
good thing I got exactly what I need for
this little girl ain't gonna get warded
by no nuts I'm the master of my own
destiny the deepest boys little girl in
the world
given that I'm a master chemist I can
surely figure out these electronics Oh
ventilations well I guess cables and
such a battery ulster my brain sir is
stumped but there seem to be numbers in
my brain maybe quickly well yeah I don't
know what I did was good oh wait so that
Bush that button just pushed other
buttons so I didn't oh hi I forgot that
I was still on my pills are you Oh No
Oh God Oh mommy daddy who did this do oh
gosh that's not okay oh poor little girl
oh and I wash away the blood that would
be nice
well oh I see this like a tube for water
oh so close water symbol I guess this is
connected to something maybe I don't
know be in the world smart is little
girl yes I can figure this one out too
hey mom and dad
wha- never mind okay so what else can we
do oh it's locked
okay I guess I can go hunt down okay so
I didn't think that I solved everything
but I didn't solve the elevator but
there's still the thing shank shank am I
supposed to remember these because I'm
not gonna yah - oh I can use the pills
down here whoa
Oh Oh in May Oh
Orton okay hello hi it's not very cute
hey I was right about the killer eyes
maybe the rabbit is angry or hungry Oh
big big robot rabbit oh what a cutie
what a cutie that's a cutie can I look
at that shank thanks for letting me look
at that I guess why did I need to look
at these shanks a Walton
okay I've looked at all of them haven't
I I guess what do I need to do now oh ah
it's a puzzle right six right six
rite-aid
left nine left eight okay so this is a
puzzle for the combination thing
upstairs
8 5 9 6 8 so 8 5 9 6 8 which is right
right left right left so the combination
is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 1 2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 oh
come on that was totally it this toad
stomach scrotes it
ah there we go okay got it
yay okay
I did it good follow me don't know what
that did oh hey hey surprised ran happy
birthday Oh a birthday party whoa
I thought you wanted to kill mr.
midnight you lied to me oh wait why'd
you in order to keep your attention
another direction I'm very sorry I drew
you my friend clean water to provide you
my dear friend
come and eat cake all right Thank You
kitty you really surprised me
Thank You Edward sir and we have
something I hope you find it is it a
shoe Wow I love the wrapping can I open
it now please I'm gonna murder you cat
what was that oh here's the thing I saw
a vision of me stabbing something
exactly
and it didn't go lots of blood
everywhere silly piano it may give your
eyes a new perception you know like we
are from is that what happens when I
take the red pills or LSD is the
ultra-reality what I see how many of you
guys out there have seen the
ultra-reality would you like some
explanations dear god no oh there's not
only one time changes I'm not sure sir I
think maybe I feel a bit dizzy over down
you mean we're about to get home did you
hear that kitty robot who arrived really
wow how exciting
all right here I go
oh oh that doesn't seem good oh dear
what's happening mr. midnight are you
all right I'm all right
but I hope this ship won't break it
sounds dangerous
it sure does mr. kitty Oh Fran you have
to help I have to drive the machine
again the automatic robber will destroy
rollers oh there's one left alive
you little bit find it fast
how is it what did you murder the rest
of them I knew you were a super murder
how do I do that sir
water that cleans the dirt maybe hiding
from your eyes okay oh my goodness kitty
I'm so scared Oh all righty then me too
Fran we have to find the kamala I really
hope the water destroys it let's go and
sadly with that I have to end there I
know I said I was gonna finish this game
all in one but something actually came
up and I have to address so I won't be
able to finish it all right now I will
get back to this very soon it'll only be
like a day or two it before this in the
next episode so expect it real soon I
will get to the end as I promised excuse
me sorry sorry for being so brief but
thank you again everybody for watching
and as always
you in the next video
Oh